تيك توك حكايه تطبيق للمقاطع المصوره
تتحول الى مصدر جدل دولي عابر للقارات
منصه اطلقت من الصين عام 2016 لتنتشر
كالنار في الهشيم خاصه في هواتف المراهقين
عبر كل الاسقع حرب عالميه على تيك توك من
الولايات المتحده الى اوروبا تضاعفت حده
الانتقادات بل الاجراءات عدد متزايد من
المشرعين الامريكيين يسعون الى حظر
التطبيق بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي
واشنطن تكشف عن تتبع التطبيق لعشرات
المواقع الحكوميه ما يعني التجسس صحيفه
هول ستريت جورنال كشفت ما هو اخطر تقرير
لشركه الامن السيبراني قال ان اكثر من 20
موقعا حكوميا في الولايات المتحده يحتوي
على شفره تتبع الويب والتي اعدتها بايت
دانس الشركه الام للتيك توك الرئيس
التنفيذي لتيك توك شوزي الاتهام وقال ان
الشركه تواجه لحظه فارقه ومحوريه التطبيق
يضم الان اكثر من 150 مليون مستخدم نشط
شهريا في الولايات المتحده اي ما يقرب من
نصف عدد السكان
المصائب لا تاتي فرادى بعد واشنطن روما
تفتح تحقيقا في انتهاك التيك توك قواعد
النشر اما اوسلو فقد نصحت موظفيها بعدم
تحميل التطبيق المنصه الصينيه الشهيره
مهدده في كل مكان
المخاطر تصل حد مقاضاتها في ايطاليا بسبب
مضمونها الذي يختلف عما يبث داخل الصين
وخارجها
الاتهامات تتراوح بين نشر محتوى سيء يشجع
على سوء التغذيه والترويج للانتحار
والتاثير على القاصرين ايضا هي تفاعلات ما
تزال مستمره في انتظار مستقبل التطبيق
المثير للجدل بلال البجدين العربيه